all right i think i should start
um hello everyone so i'm going to talk
about the
um vector visualization in in this talk
um so first of all
i want to talk about um just briefly
what vector plot is
just so like people can understand the
rest of my talk
and uh um vector plan is not something
new
it has been hit um in the product for
for a few versions
and but in uh 12.1 i think
we um introduced a bunch of
options uh that make vector plot
much easier to use and that
concept is extended to other vector plot
families so i want to talk about that
and i would give a list of of the
visualizations
that we have been working on that is
vector plot related
and then i will talk about um these new
options in detail especially the vector
points
which is um which is the main topic here
um so first of all
um what is vector plot um i mean if you
are familiar with vector plot this is
just some maybe this is just a refresh
for you
so um this is a a picture that i just
got from the internet
and um it is something that we all can
relate to so when we were young we were
asked to draw the magnetic field
of a magnet so the way we do that is
just we play this uh magnetic compass
and then we just see how uh the arrows
is pointing
and well i'm certainly that
i'm certain that we didn't have this
many compass when we were young
but if you do place that many of compass
under the magnetic then you will see all
the arrows is pointing
from the positive to the negative and
the vector flood is just a perfect tool
to
model this so here i have a vector field
that represents this so there are two
particles i mean i'm
simplify the magnetite the magnet here
into two points
one is done positive which is x minus
two
and the other one is x plus two and one
has positive charge one has negative
charge
and this is the field how it looks like
so if i
substitute the x and y with the position
and i will get a vector
so this is the vector that we want to
visualize
the way we visualize this is
we put an error at the position
and the length of the arrow uh that in
this version we made them
a unit length so they are all the same
lengths
so what we are trying to visualize uh
with the color is the magnitude
of the vector so that's that is why the
legend here is four
so with higher value here um
um that means the the higher magnitude
it
is and you can see that this is um
representing the the magnetic field on
the right
so that is the vector plot so once once
again
so we are trying to visualize the vector
field
and for every point x comma y we have a
vector
and the the arrow is the direction of
the vector
and the color is the magnitude of the
vector
and another popular plot
in conjunction with vector plot is the
stream plot
and the stream plot is essentially
solving this differential equation so
what
this differential equation is saying is
that
so for given point the tangential of
that point
is exactly the vector
right so if it's just like you know
you know the speed of a position that's
the definition of that
and um so that is what we have here
the um the derivative of the x and y
is the vector of that point
so by solving this differential equation
we can get x of t and y of t
and that is continuous function
that we we are drawing in the stream
plot
okay so it's not established um we can
look at the new options that we
introduced
for vector plot um so the first one
is the vector points vector points is
just that
option an option that you can specify
to say that how i want to sample the
vector field
so remember the vector field that we we
provide for the vector plot is a
continuous
function i mean what i meant is that the
whole field is continuous
but we if we want to
visualize this vector field
we have to have some simple points so
that is controlled by the vector points
so say that we have these points
placed in the field and like i said
before
by default we are making the vectors the
same length
and the packing of these points becomes
important so we
so we have the maximum vectors
in the field and each vector is paired
in a way that
it is not touching
and uh that is that when they are all
the same length
and but that is not the only thing you
can do
certainly you can say that i want the
length of the vector
to represent the magnitude in that case
you can use
vector sizes to say that what is the
minimum and the maximum vector length i
want to have
and the other one is just how you want
to um
change the look of the vector by
specifying
the vector aspect ratio so this is just
purely um
that aesthetic
um so by default like i said we do not
have any vector scaling so that's why
all the vectors have the same length
but you can enable this vector scaling
and then you can see this is actually
the traditional view
that we previously had then you have a
different length on the vectors
so that's controlled by vector scaling
and we also introduce
vector range vector range works just
like flat range
except that is not on the x and y it's
actually on the magnitude of
of the vectors and this vector range
works well with the clipping style
say that i specify my vector range
for this vector plot so that i'm only
showing
a range of vectors and clipping style is
controlled
clipped away vectors
so i'll talk more about this later and
another option
uh is vector markers we have quite a few
vector markers they have been there for
for few versions but we also uh make
them
we also introduce some control system
so that we can place the vectors in
different way and i will talk about this
in detail the other two options brett
has talked about
which is very straightforward is the
region boundary style and region filling
style
that is implying that vector plots and
its family
can take a region function and we will
see that
all right so these are a bunch of vector
related visualization functions we are
supporting
so a vector plot stream plot vector
density plot
so this is the density plot itself
is a continuous representation of the
vector field
and is overlaid um on the background
um and then we have the 3d version of
vector flash 3d
and we have the slice vector plus 3d
which is a
volume plot that is that i have the
whole
vector field in 3d and i only want to
visualize
a slice of it and and how the vectors is
flowing on last slice
and that is use the that is using this
function slice vector plus 3d we also
have a geo vector plot and geostream
plot that
normal has talked about so i will not go
into the detail but they work just like
the vector plot the um the data input
is slightly different but they are all
well documented
the other two that i will not talk about
is a complex vector plot which
is vector plot but we are visualizing on
the complex value
and the complex stream plot because
there will be talked
by my colleague tim mcdevitt at
i think 12 um no i think
at one o'clock today
um so let's move on to the options we
um that's the main
topic of the day that is vector points
so how we sample the vector fields
is the key point to have a quality
vector plot so say i'm plotting
this vector field y minus x
and the sin the the simple way i can
sample this field is i create a grid
which is just on the integers and i can
just
put the grader in the vector plot and
that's actually how it
was before and in in the 12
that we introduced a few different pad
and packings that i will talk about in
just a few minutes
in just a few seconds but i want to also
mention that
um this vector point allows you
to specify not just on the integers you
can specify any
random real points so for example
so these are the points that i want to
sample
my vector field and i will just
put that point into vector field and
this these are the vector
uh these are the vectors as the
positions
as the points are and like i said before
this color is coded by the magnitude of
the vector um
and there isn't really a good way to
know what are the what the magnitudes
are if you you are not
actually computing the magnitudes
outside the vector plot
so one of the uh i think the best way to
to to know that is calling this plot
legends
out and then you can see what's the
magnitude
and this becomes very important when you
are using the vector range
and there are situations
that you do want the vector lengths to
be represented
by the magnitude of the vectors that is
that is the the time that you use vector
scaling go to
automatic i'll talk about more lists
so besides that we also have the
functionality that you can say that i
want to sample
uh the vectors uh the the vector field
over a region
so here i have a a joint region
which has two disks so it's
directly inside the arguments
of x comma y
um and we can also like i said before
this is a spatial function the slice
vector plus 3d
the the vectors is actually sampled
on the service only and this service is
controlled by the second argument here
this is the preset one which is called
centric cut sphere we have many presets
so if you open up the documentation of
slice vector class 3d
there are a bunch of over there you can
look at
so let's move on to the sampling method
by default we are using hexagonal in
i think since 12.1 before it's using the
regular one
now we are using this uh more tightly
packed
version and we also have a
method called mesh for the 2d i will
talk about
and for the 3d we have hexagonal and we
have something called face
centered cubic it is a different packing
algorithm
they look very similar to the hexagonal
but if you look closely
here they are actually different the
difference is subtle
but i'm sure that there will be some
cases that you would want
you know one over another and like i
said before
all these vector functions
they they accept that the free form
points
and um to nicely see that hexagonal how
impact it is is to use
um this vector markers circle arrow
so it just draws a circle um around them
around the arrow so you can see that
they are tightly packed
and the mesh
is based on the geometry of the
corresponding service
so if i'm planting the magnitude of this
vector field in the plus 3d
this is what i get and if i
call the mesh out you can see that there
are tons of meshes
in this service and um
the sampling method vector points could
measure in a vector plot
is based on the meshes in the plus 3d
we thin them out so that they don't look
um
overwhelmingly um complicated
um but the reason we introduced this is
that there are
cases when you have a region the region
um will look
more like the region if you have um
the samples sampled at the mesh points
instead of
regular grid um
the other function that we have is the
vector another function we have is
vector density plot
so in this case if i plot this
with the same field here and you can see
that this is a
nice representation of both of these
vector plot and plus 3d
the vector points besides that you can
say that i want this hexagonal you can
also
specify what how many vector points
uh per the per direction so like
here i say that i want 10 points on the
x direction and 10 points on the y
direction
so i've changed to 15 here
um then you can see that the y direction
has
more vectors and the vector
lengths get shrunk a little bit so that
they have
still have the tightly packed packing
and we also optimized so that um
the number of the vectors sampled
um has and has taken a spec ratio and
image size into consideration so this is
will be in 12.2
so this is going to be helpful when you
have different
you know x and y ranges
and in the 3d like i said before the
difference
is kind of it's kind of subtle you
probably won't just
observe it you know from the output of
this
but um yeah but i think you'll just have
to take my words they are different
right so we'll just take a quick example
on
the 3d version so this is the same idea
i have two particles
uh this is in the three-dimensional
space
and um the static potential is just like
this
and if we draw the contour plot
then i can have these iso services of
the potential and at different iso
values or control values
and if i draw the same vector field in
the vector plus 3d then i have a bunch
of vectors
and if i put them together here then i
can visualize
how the vectors how the vector field
looked like
and how the potential field the reason
i'm choosing this example from the
documentation actually
is because we can now just use select a
slice vector plus 3d
and to see that just in one function we
do not we do not need to
generate two different plots and put
them together
so this is the same thing so besides the
preset
slices i can use
actually any boolean function on the
second argument this is
the isoservices
okay so and so another um
option is vector range like i said
before it works like a plot range but
it's on the magnitude
so for example in this vector field the
vectors magnitude
gets explode and it gets explode
exponentially
growth on the corners
so uh
and that's why you see mostly blue in
the center
and yellow on the corners so in order to
use
vector range we really need to know what
the ranges are so
that's why i bring up these plot plot
legends
and now i can say that the vector range
i only want to show from 5 to 200
and that's this ring and i just seen
that my clipping style is go to none
but i can say that my claims dial go to
red below
5 and blue above 200 and that's
how you get the colors
so that's very straightforward so
right and with the same example i'm
going to show off the option vector
scaling
so vector scaling the reason we have
this is that we
the reason we turn it off is that if we
turn it
on by default this is what you get in a
plot
that has high values on the vector on
the magnitudes
i mean the difference is high the most
of the
the majority of the vectors is going to
be invisible
and and that is not desired because
apparently there are some interesting
behavior here but they are just
saturated by the high values on the
corners
so that's why we turn it off by default
but i mean
um i mean even if you i mean you can set
that i want
the scaling to be logged even in this
case it is still
difficult to see what happened in the in
the center
um so with scanning function go to
vector scaling go to none
you can have all them be shown and we
use the color to indicate
the magnitude
okay all right and this
this is another options and that you can
change the
the look of the vector plot and uh this
is called vector markers
so by default we are using um just the
arrows these are the points i previously
generated but like i said before you can
have
uh much more other
marker values that we can have i'm just
taking a few here
with the arrow the circle arrow double
error
or just dot arrows so what i'm trying to
i'm going to try to show you another
scene is that we can actually so if i
do the epilogue
of the point
here end points
oh i need to put the primitive here
so you can see that this is how the
vectors are
placed but the problem of this is that
there are some applications that you do
want the arrows
to be placed um in the beginning
or in the end
the way to control that you can use
place
and say start
then you can have the arrow place it at
the beginning
if you do the end and it is on the end
so this is going to be useful for you if
it's for any reason you don't want it to
be centered
all right
all right the last set of options is
region filling style and region boundary
style
like i said they are very
straightforward the
they are very useful um when you have
region functions
uh specified in the vector plot so i'm
taking the same example so the first
slide
and here i say that i only want my
vector field be sampled
in this region which is outside of these
two circles
there you have it and by default uh
there is a region boundary style and
there is a region filling style
i can turn them off then you get this
and besides the region function that you
can specify
like i said before you can also specify
within the argument
that is the x and y you can specify i
only want to visualize
within this rectangle
and here i use these two options to
stylize them
together if i put them together
this will has a better representation of
that
the previous the the the very first
flight that i have shown
so this is um
you know an application of this region
feeling style and region boundary style
um that will conclude my talk so all
these
options is going to be applied in uh the
vector plot all these vector plot
families
so um and um there is still
um a few kinks that we are still working
out for 12.2
so um and we are continuously
working on the new options um in
the vector plot families so um
if something that is not working in 12.1
for you with these options it might have
worked in 12.2 so i just want to point
that out
well thank you so if they're if there's
any questions i will start to answer
now
yes the notebook will be uploaded right
after i finish this talk
um a lot of i mean some of these
features are in 12.2
so if you evaluate you might you may not
see the same results
all right
oh hi itai
so i saw you rest your hand so
okay can you hear me yes okay
uh extra security warnings and big sir
when are we going to get the
um string plot 3d it is
under development so we are actually
actively working on that one because we
know it's something people want
so but i have no promises
well thank you very much oh is there any
way to get the same scaling in the
second vector plot
in the first one um
yes so well i assume that you're talking
about this one right francisco
um
the same scaling i assume that you're
talking about the same way
vector length um
it is not very easy um you can get
um so the option vector scaling
besides like the log or automatic and
none
it also allows you to um
oh does it i'm not sure if allows you to
specify a custom scaling
um oh i don't think we
allowed that for this version
if you do want that the same sizes
you can
you can use vector sizes to scale them
so vector size
it actually can go beyond zero to one it
can go to a two or something
and that's how you can control that and
you can also
have the same density of the vector
points
that just inside this uh region
um so i would say that the best way to
do that is that you have your vector
points
sampled in both
vector plots and then when you stick
them together they will look
they are the same
all right thank you so we have a office
hour that is going on right now
so if you want to join me there
then i can answer more questions over
there thank you very much